hey everyone this is luca
i'm really excited to tell you that my
course on the basics of r for ecologists
is up and running so if you're an
ecologist and you're just getting
started with r and feeling that
frustration of the learning curve and
just need something that can take you by
the hand to really understand the solid
fundamentals of using r for ecology
check out my course just go to
r4ecology.com
there's a link also down below and hope
to see you there
[Music]
hey everyone it's luca here
i want to do a really quick video
showing you the essentials of r for
ecology cheat sheet going through each
one of the functions on that cheat sheet
which all together probably comprise
about 80 percent of every function
you'll ever need to use an r as an
ecologist or biologist more generally
so let's get started
first we're just going to create some
data really quick that we can use for
demonstrating all of these functions
and there we have it so here we have a
little bit of data that we can use to
understand how these functions work so
don't worry i'm going to include all of
this code down in the comments below or
in the in the blog post that i'm going
to be posting with this video so you can
just copy and paste this into the start
of your code all right now let's get to
it so the first function is probably the
most common function you'll ever need to
know in r and that is the concatenate
function or just c function for short
and this is for creating vectors so as
we did above here with number vector and
so when we run number vector we get
these values and we can also create a
vector using character variables so here
we have spp1 or species 1 species 3
species 2 and species 3 and when we
created this and run species vector we
have this vector of character values
okay next we have sum
so with sum that simply adds up all the
different numbers in a vector together
so if we do some
numvec and run that we get 20 because 3
plus 6 plus 3 plus 8 is 20. if we have
an n a in these data so let's say we had
a vector inside here that contains
everything in numvec but then also an n
a value or a missing value
you'll actually get an n a because by
definition n a means you don't know what
that value is so because you don't know
what one of these values is you cannot
actually calculate the sum of all of
these and you get an n a however you can
add in an argument n a dot remove or n a
dot rm equals true and when we run this
it ignores that n a and sums everything
else together
next we have length
this simply tells you either the length
of a vector or the number of columns in
a data frame so for if we do numvec in
here
we get 4 because there are four elements
in that vector if we look at this data
frame here that we created let's just
take a look at it running that we have
one column of numvec one column of
species vac and this is the whole data
frame together now if we
run
length for the data frame we get just
the number of columns in this case two
columns
all right moving on unique
unique tells us how many unique elements
there are within a vector so for example
if we put in number vec
or numvec
we have a three we have a six and we
have an eight and the reason we don't
have four values here is because the
three repeats itself twice
sometimes you want to know what the
total number of unique values within a
vector are and a simple way to do that
let's say we want to know how many
unique species there are inside species
vec so let's put species vec in here
and when we run that we get these unique
species ids but let's say we had a
really long list and we can't just count
that it's 3 we can actually use the
length function around the unique
function
and now we can find out that there are
three unique different types of species
inside species vec
all right next as dot numeric
this is useful because sometimes when
you load data into r for whatever reason
it turns a what should be a number
vector into or a numeric vector into a
character vector so let's say for
example we had
we had a character vector actually was
supposed to be a number vector but
actually
it somehow loaded into r as
and the reason this can happen
is because
i'll show you another example
let's say these are all numeric
but then somewhere in your data
your field assistant entered in the
letter o instead of
the number zero
and so when you
upload these data and take a look at
charvek it actually turns all of these
numbers into characters including that
original o
so if we use as dot numeric put that in
there
we'll get this warning message that says
n a is introduced by coercion and that's
because that o isn't actually a real
number uh in fact it's not a fake number
either it's not a number so we are left
with these numbers here 3 5 2 1 5 and an
n a value for where that o used to be
next we have the log function
i'm not going to give a full example of
using the log function here simply
because we don't have a lot of data for
this quick demonstration
but simply put this extracts the natural
logarithm of a value or of the values in
a vector so if we put
in here let's just say the number 3 and
run that this is the natural log of 3
1.098612
if we have a vector values here
num vec
it calculates the
logarithm of all of these numbers and
this is useful usually when you're
visualizing or plotting data that's
skewed to one side and you want to be
able to visualize it a little bit nicer
i find myself using the log function
quite a bit and then you just have to
indicate on one of your axes that the
data are log transformed
next we have the sort function
this is used to a arrange a vector
numerically or alphabetically so if we
have our num back here
and run that it'll rearrange all the
values in numvac starting with the
lowest going up to the highest
or if we do
use our species vector it will organize
them alphabetically and
actually it also organized them
numerically because spp is the same for
all of these values but the 1 2 3 and 3
was used for rearranging these values
but if let's say we had a
bunch of different letters
d s and a if we run sort
whoops we actually need to make that
into a vector there we go
try that again it has rearranged them
with a starting first then d and then s
we can also reverse that order by saying
so if we if we ran
sort on number we get three three six
eight and we can add in this argument
decreasing
equals
true and now the values will be
decreasing starting with eight six three
and three next we have this is dot n a
function
is dot n a is super useful use it almost
all the time because we're always
encountering values that might be
n a or missing
essentially what this does is it tells
us is a value an n a or not so if we add
in a vector here let's make up
let's make up a vector one two three
five
there was no two it's just one three
five
n a
run that
we get false false false and true
because one three and five are not n a
but n a is an a so we got a true there
the reason this is useful is normally
for most other values we could say
let's say we want to find out actually
let's create this as a new vector
we'll call it newvec
and let's say we want to see which of
these values is
greater than
2
so we'll say
nuvec
is greater than
2
and we get a false true true and n a
because we don't know what that value is
the 3 and 5 are greater than 2 the 1 is
less than 2 so we get false let's say we
want to see which values are equal to
three
we get false and then we get true for
the three false and then n a that makes
sense but now let's see if we want to
find out which values are an a so we put
equals n a
ah but look we get four n a's that's
because n a means we don't know what it
is so you can't actually say nuvec
equals n a because that's like saying
nuvac equals i don't know what
so that's what we use this is.n a for
that's useful if you want to identify
which values are n a and want to remove
them from your data set often times i'll
use is.n a with an exclamation point
in front of it which actually makes it
not
so rather than giving you false false
false true it reverses those by applying
this not statement and when you run that
you get true true true false so
sometimes for example if you want to
remove nas from a data set you can use
this and index your data using this
so let's
we'll we'll actually use nuvec here
instead of that to make it a little
simpler to see
if we index nuvec with this true true
true false
we are left with just one three and five
and successfully remove that n a value
from our data
all right next
we have the
in
percent in percent operator whatever
that's called not technically a function
but super super useful nonetheless uh
used for finding what items match
between two vectors usually used for
matching character values between two
vectors but can be used for numbers as
well
let me show you how this works
let's use the example from the cheat
sheet
vec
in
and let's create this new vector
species
one and species
four so what this does is it says
here we've got species vector we've got
this vector of four different well three
different species but four different
elements and then we have this other
vector of these two individuals here
and what this says is within species vec
which of these values
are also found inside this vector so
when we run this we get true false false
false when we look at what species
vector is
species the first value is species 1
which is found in this vector so that's
true and species 3 species 2 and species
3 are not found inside this vector so we
get false false false for each of those
now if we reverse this
and run that we get true and false
because again species 1 is found inside
species vec but species 4 is not so
remember that whatever goes before the
percent in percent is the vector for
which you're going to get trues and
falses to see whether these elements
also occur in this vector
so next we have a really cool set of
functions for parsing date values up
until now we've been using the base
package which comes installed with r we
don't have to load any new packages but
for this next function we're going to
load the lubridate
package if it's not installed already
use install.packages
lubridate
i have it installed already so i'm not
going to run that
so i'm just going to run
library
blueberry date
to load that package so what lubridate
gives us is this really cool set of
functions that we can create
using a y an m and a d y stands for year
m stands for month d stands for
day
so we can create a function y month
day we can say day month
year
we can say year day month
you get the idea you can do any
combination of these three and so you
want to order the year day and month
based on the date that you are trying to
parse so let's say we have
let's say we somehow entered in our
field data the dates as let's say
2016
slash
june
comma
13.
now if this is just a character value
nothing special no date object here but
let's say all of our data are in this
format and you're going geez how am i
going to make r know that these are
actually date values and not some weird
format that i decided to use
well we'll use this function here in
this case
y for year first
month comes next day comes last make
sure this order is the same as the order
of values in here and we run it and
voila we now have a date object where r
knows that this is a date and we can
tell that because it's transformed this
format into this nice standard date
format in r we can also save this as an
object
my date
and take a look at that
if you run the function class and then
put my date inside there we can see that
it is now a date object
so what's really cool about these
functions is it will take just about any
type of date formatting you can think of
so let's say another example from the
cheat sheet is
13th
of
june
2016.
in this case we'll say day month and
year
run that
and we get that same date object next we
have a few cool functions for creating
vectors we have the sequence function
seq
and it's used to create a vector of
values that increment at a regular rate
so for example we could say takes a few
arguments so from
to
and by
so from let's say we want to go from 0
to
10
and we want to go by twos
and when we run that we get the value 0
2 4 6 8 10. if we had put in
0.5 here
it would also start at 0 and go to 10
but in increments of 0.5
then we have the function
rep or repeat and this is used to create
a vector with a repeating set of values
so we could say
first argument isn't called x we'll say
x is all the values from 1 to 3 so
remember if you just look at that it's
just 1 2 and 3.
and so we'll repeat that
times equals 2 so that will take this
pattern here repeat it twice so now we
get a vector that goes 1 2 3 1 2 3.
if instead of times however
we say
h equals two it will take each
individual element of this vector repeat
it and then go on to the next element
so now we have one one two two three
three and finally to complete the basic
functions i'm going to go over one of my
favorite functions which is the grepple
function
g-r-e-p-l
and this is used for finding which
elements of a character vector contain a
particular string of text
so for example we could say
let's say so the first argument is the
pattern we're searching for so let's say
we're searching for anything that
contains this number three in the
character string
and we'll search within the vector of
species vec
so let's take a look at that
look at species back again we have
species one species three species two
species three
species three and species three each
contain that value of three inside it so
we get a return back that goes false
true false true
if for example we had said s p b
now or maybe just sp which of these
contain that string of text we'll get
true for everything of course and so on
so common way that i use the grepple
function is for subsetting data frames
or vectors so for example we could say
if we look at data frame this is the
data frame we created before it has a
column of numvec and species vec
and if we want to subset this let's say
grepple
let's say we want to extract all of
species three or all the species that
contain the species names that contain
the value of three we'll say
three here just like we did before
and then
data frame
we'll use we could have just put in
species back on its own but since we're
subsetting this data frame it's better
practice to include a reference to the
column within the data frame that we're
filtering by so again if we just take a
look at this part
run that we get false true false true
true for species 3 and species 3
and to filter this data frame we also
add a comma here because these are all
of the rows we want to keep and we're
going to apply this to all the columns
and
there it is
now we have filtered this data frame
down to just species 3. so that's it for
the basic functions now let's continue
on with
loading data i don't have any data sets
to load for this quick tutorial but i
will just quickly show you how these
functions work
read.css
all you have to do is put in the path
for the data set you're trying to load
so actually to make this work and a
little bit nicer for you let's actually
reverse those functions let's use
write.csv
to save our special data frame that we
created here and then reload it in using
read.csv so we'll just save that as
dataframe.csv
and the first argument of the write.csv
is the actual
data frame in this case we called it
dataframe
and it will save right in the
base directory where we are working
so to get a look at that let's go on
ahead to actually another function the
get working directory or g
e t
w
d
this will show us where our base working
directory is located
here in my case it's located in this
user's lucanoida documents
entrepreneurship grad ecologists youtube
r tutorials folder which is actually
this folder right here let's say we want
to
save it inside this folder here which is
tutorial scripts so i'm just going to
add in here tutorial
scripts slash dataframe.csv
and it will save right in here
there it is
all right so now let's use
this read.csv to load it back in
we have to use the same file path
location
and
we'll save it into a new file let's call
it
data frame
uploaded
now let's take a look at data frame
uploaded
and there it is now interestingly it
added this extra column of one two three
four and that's just because when you
use write.csv it helps to add in
row.names
equals false because for some reason
right.csv likes to add in these row
names whenever you're saving a data
frame so if we run that again
and now load
this data frame one more time and take a
look
now we have only those original two
columns that we had before
great
now
we have this other function we haven't
talked about
set working directory this is to set
where the working directory is going to
be in this case we used get working
directory to see where it was and if we
wanted to change where the working
directory is we could use that however i
include it here to make a point
it's a really important and good idea
not to ever use set working directory
instead go to file new project and
create oh let's save that okay
new directory your existing directory
new project directory name create that
project and then start creating
scripts in there you can see here i have
a project called youtube r tutorials the
great thing about using rstudio projects
is that it creates that base directory
right where the youtube r tutorials
project file is based so if we go back
one folder and scroll down here you'll
see i have this youtuber
tutorials.rproj file and that's
automatically created when you create a
new project in r the nice thing about
this is now if i take this entire folder
with the r project in it and email it to
you share it with a friend
send it wherever i want to send it
and you run this same script you will
also be able to load up these data from
this tutorial scripts folder because the
base directory this part when you use
get working directory this part of it of
everything will change depending on your
computer and where you saved this
project but youtube are tutorials that
base directory will always be the same
and relative to whoever is using that
project
so my spiel is done don't use set
working directory use our project files
and
let's go on from there next let's create
some custom functions so up until now
we've been using functions that are
already created and built in with r or
other packages that contain these
functions but sometimes you just need to
create that perfect function that fits
your job exactly as you need to do it
and there's just nothing else out there
so
here we go so to create a function
you use the function function
let's name this function
my
func
and by the way if you hear something
that sounds like a dying dog outside
that is actually a sea lion that's not
dying that's actually quite happy and
roaming around in the water defending
its territory uh just wanted to
alleviate any anxiety that that sound
might be giving you um i'm based in the
galapagos very fortunately so and so
there are random wildlife sounds that
will fill this tutorial as well
just a heads up there okay now back to
the my function calling it myfunk and
into that we're putting this function
function
the arguments of the function function
are whatever arguments you want your
function to take in so we'll just call
the simplest way to do it is we'll just
call it x we could have called it
whatever we wanted so our function will
take in
one value that's called x or one
variable that's called x and then you
use these curly brackets
to enter the contents of the function
let's say we want a function that will
modify the value of x in this weird way
so we'll create this variable x mod
and
to modify to create x mod we're going to
take x
add 5 to it
and then take the result of that and
multiply it by 3. there's one more thing
we have to add to this function and that
is a return function this function tells
r what aspect of the inside of this
function to actually return or output to
the user
in this case we're going to say
xmod
so looking through this
we've got this function function where
it will take this value of x and then it
will
take that value of x x add 5 multiply
that whole thing by 3
save that as x mod and then the function
returns the contents of xmod so if we
run this
nothing happens
but the function is now saved
here in our environment under the
functions category
and so to run this function
all we have to do is use myfunk and now
we can use parentheses with it just like
you would with any other function and
the first
argument that it takes the only argument
that it takes is x
and that let's just put in
numvec and there it is
looking at numvac again
it takes each of these values so for
example 3
3 plus 5 is 8 times 3 is 24.
6 plus 5 is 11 times 3 is 33 and so on
and it returns all those values and of
course because this was the only value
in the function we could have also just
ignored that x equals and just written
it like that and we would get the same
result
okay
now let's move on to a few miscellaneous
functions
actually two of those functions we've
already gone over up here the
install.packages function that we use
for installing any new packages that our
computer does not currently have
installed but once they are installed
you do not need to install them again
you only need to use the library
function to load up those packages
whenever you have a new r session
i'm going to delete this because this
error right here actually i'm going to
comment it out there we go all right so
that's what the library function does
you always need to load it load a new
package into your our working space into
your
new session as it's called
whenever you are working with it again
if i reloaded r and didn't run this i
would get an error if i tried to run
these functions because it doesn't know
where they are you can think of it as
installing dot install that packages is
you going to home depot and buying a
bunch of new really cool fancy tools
and then library is
you going into your shop and pulling out
those tools and getting them ready to
use okay there's a few other
miscellaneous functions here that are
useful
there is the help function
if you ever don't know what a function
does just use the help function on that
function so let's say we want to know
what grepple does
all we have to do is help
grepple
run that and it will automatically open
this little help window here to the
right
where we can see
all about grep and grepple and all these
other functions that are related and
what they do and how they work the
different arguments in them
and then the best part that i usually
scroll down to immediately when i really
want to figure out how a function works
is the
examples section where you can see
concrete examples in r for how the
particular functions work and you can
just copy and paste them right into here
and see what happens another way to
access
this
help database here is simply to go to
help in this panel here type in the
function you're looking for
hit enter and it will come up on here
and then you can search within this page
just by clicking here
let's say we want to look up just
grepple not not
grep or anything else we got it there
you can keep scrolling through and see
all the times that that word
occurs in this
help file then we have the
data function this is fun because we can
access a whole bunch of built-in data
sets for playing around and
experimenting in r as we are learning if
we run the data function with empty
parentheses nothing in it
we get this list of all these different
data sets with a short little
description of what they are
let's say we want to look at a data set
on the survival of passengers on the
titanic
okay so notice that the dataset's called
titanic with a capital t
we can go here type in titanic
and run that and now if we look at our
environment we have this new
data set here titanic and then the
values for some reason it says promise
here i have no idea
what that means i guess r is promising
that they're going to give us the data
i don't know what that means either way
you just click on it and it's right
there
um or or if we if we had run it um then
you could save it as its own file
my titanic
data
doing that also
turns it from saying
promise here to actually an actual data
set so if we take a look at um
oh i guess it's a
it's like a weird
this this isn't a good data set example
but the point because it has all these
different
components to it but anyway the point is
that
you run this data function with the name
of the data set and you can extract
those data you'll notice up here that's
what i did with trees data so i ran data
trees saved trees as its own data frame
called trees data
and that's this right here
and then i did a few modifications to
add a few columns to it
i added this column of light and then
used these functions that i already went
over rep and c
to create this vector of
sun and shade treatments when we run
just that
you can see creates this vector of sun
and shade and we're just adding that
into the tree data set and then making
sun
and shade into a factory using as.factor
so if we take a look at tree data now
it's the same as before and we also have
this extra column of shade and sun
values you can also learn more about the
data that you've that you've loaded in
using the data function by
searching by using the help function so
we'll put titanic
or actually let's put trees that's more
ecological than titanic data
we'll put trees into the
help function and here we have this
really nice explanation for this trees
data set which explains what these
different columns mean how they were
measured any sources or references for
where these data came from and a few
examples of playing around with these
data all right so that's it for the
miscellaneous functions and that's it
for side one of the essential functions
of our cheat sheet
if you like this video so far and want
to finally feel confident with
visualizing and managing your own data
in r as an ecologist then be sure to
check out my online course on the basics
of r for ecologists the course is
completely self-paced and i take you by
the hand through all the essentials of r
using ecological data sets as well as
exercises to test your learning along
the way the course is also fully
accessible to everyone regardless of
financial ability so just click below to
learn more and sign up for the upcoming
enrollment period
okay now let's get on to some basic data
visualization the most common and basic
function that you'll ever want to use
for plotting your data in r is just
called
plot
it's great for creating scatter plots as
well as box plots as well as a few other
things but i'm going to limit the
conversation to that because those are
probably the most common plots you'll
ever need to create
so let's use our tree data for this so
the plot function takes an argument data
equals
tree data remember we were just taking a
look at that data set just before let's
take a look at it one more time so i can
just show you what those variables are
girth is the diameter of the tree height
is the height of the tree volume is the
volume
girth is in inches height is in feet and
volume is in cubic feet i believe and
this is this made up additional data set
of whether the tree was in the sun or in
the shade so if we so we'll use this
data argument to tell the plot function
that we're going to be using the tree
data
and then all we have to do is put in the
names of the
columns that we want to plot
and we'll say
height
and then we'll use this tilde symbol
which can be thought of as
tilde equals
is a function of
or
more simply you can just say
whatever
is on the left of the tilde
tilde
is
the
y variable
or
it's what will appear
on the y-axis
so here let's have tree height on the
y-axis
and
let's do tree volume
on the x-axis
and when we run this
we get a nice little plot
of
height on the y-axis volume on the
x-axis a nice little simple scatter plot
we can also create a box plot if the x
variable in this case volume is a
categorical variable
so let's keep height there but instead
of volume let's look at sun versus shade
i think we called that column light
if we run that
now we get a simple box plot with sun
and shade and the box plots created
around those values
of height
the next most essential plotting
function is the hist function or
histogram function there's so many times
that you want to just quickly visualize
what your data look like how are they
distributed what kind of data are you
working with you just collected those
data you just came back from the field
enter them all what's the first thing
you're going to look at gosh
do my data look reasonable are they
crazy are there some crazy outliers out
there let's take a quick look using the
hist function
let's just use
tree data
dollar sign
height
so it's a capital h i guess
let's look at a
distribution of tree heights in our data
set
and there it is
okay finally sometimes when we create
plots we also want to add lines to them
let's take a look at this scatter plot
that we had up here
plot that one more time let's say that
we want to add a line to this a best fit
line that shows the relationship between
tree height and tree volume let's say
it's a linear relationship for the sake
of simplicity let's create a quick model
this kind of gets a little bit more
advanced on the essential functions of
our cheat sheet we'll go back to this
later but let's create a simple model
we'll call it
fitted model
and we'll use the lm function which
stands for linear model and this
actually takes the same syntax as the
plot function
height is a function of volume and the
data are the tree data
this is going to be our fitted model and
then we're going to plot these data i'm
just rearranging the order here
we're going to plot this scatter plot
and then we're going to
use the function a b line
now remember with a linear model you've
got an a coefficient and a b coefficient
so for a linear model
going back to some basic algebra y
equals a plus b x
that is the formula for a linear model
an a b line means give us an a give us a
b
and we will create a line for you
so the nice thing is that when we look
at this fitted model
the fiddle fitted model returns these
two coefficients the intercept which is
the a and the slope of the volume which
is
b
so if we
enter that fitted model right inside
this a b line function right after we
plotted the data
we have this line that is thrown right
on top but sometimes you don't just want
a nice fitted line you want to mark
certain thresholds in the data but using
vertical or horizontal lines to do that
still use the a b line function
but we can use v for vertical equals so
let's say we want a vertical line
at a volume of 40.
so we'll say maybe line v equals 40. and
there we have a vertical line at volume
equals 40
or maybe we'll do a b line
h for horizontal at
height equals 85.
and there we have it now let's move on
to working with data frames
i
just created this little heading here
didn't create it for the other sections
doesn't matter let's just start working
with data frames now
i'm never really sure if data frames
should be one word or two words
word and other applications always tell
me that i spelled data frames wrong wow
look if r studio is telling me that i
spelled data frames wrong by having them
together then maybe it is really just
data space frames
all right so the most common function
that i've used when working with data
frames is just the
names function and what this does is it
quickly allows us to see the names of
all the columns in our data frame so if
we use our original data frame
here
you can see that one column is called
numvec another it's called species vec
if we use the names function for
our tree data
we have grth volume
girth height volume and light and we can
also use the names function to rename
column headings so for example
let's index out
just the column of girth so that's just
the first value of name so if we run
that we get just girth and into that
we're going to rename it as dbh which
stands for diameter at breast height
which is a fancier way of saying girth
and run that and now we take a look at
tree data again
and the first column name has been
renamed and if we take a look at the
names for tree data one more time by
just selecting that and running that
alone dbh height volume and light
i often use it for
quickly looking at the names of a data
frame when i'm trying to refer or index
certain parts of a data frame and i just
forgot what that column was called next
we have the data.frame
function which is what we use to create
simple data frames when we have a bunch
of vectors that we want to bring
together into one data frame and if you
recall up here that's what we did with
the two vectors that we created when we
started
numvec
species vect and then we use data.frame
to combine these two vectors into one
data frame now note that both of these
vectors need to be the same length with
one exception you can have vectors that
are a length of one so for example let's
create a new column and we'll call it
my
new column because i'm that original
equals
let's just say my new column we would
just want the value of 2 inside my new
column why not
when we run that and look at data frame
we have this new column of twos and the
reason that worked is because
two in this case is one element it's the
same as a vector of just this one
element is evenly divisible into the
number of rows here so we get to
divide it into
i'm not making any sense the point is
that two is a length of one and you can
easily fit the two into each
okay you know what i can't explain this
let me show you another example if we
had said
one comma two so now we have a vector of
the value one and two and run that it
will still work
because now it will repeat the one and
two
throughout this entire data frame
however if we had
three values one two and four
that won't evenly fit within the
available space of this data frame and
we'll get an error
error in data frame
arguments imply differing number of rows
there it is
so
you usually never have to do this but
just letting you know that that's an
option maybe i shouldn't have told you
next we have actually speaking of
telling people more than they need to
know
i'm probably going to remove data.frame
from future
cheat sheets from the future versions of
this essentials of our cheat sheet
because there is a far superior way to
make data frames in r and those are
called tibbles so instead of dataframe
data.frame
let's create our first
my table
again very original and here instead of
dataframe we're going to use the
function tibble which does the exact
same thing that data.frame does creating
a data frame except the data frame is
now really cool and superior and it's
not called a data frame anymore it's
called a tibble or maybe you call it a
type of data frame a table type of data
i don't know anyway it stands for tidy
table when we run that
oh we can't find the function table and
that's because we have to load up the
package d plier first
to work with tibbles
when we run that
and again you can install the package if
you don't have d plier first
it stands for data pliers so remember
you use pliers for bending and
manipulating and changing things and
wrangling things and so that's what deep
plier is but for data now we should be
able to run this
and take a look at my tibble
and there it is we have up here it
clearly tells us that it's a table so
thank you very much for that it shows us
that it is four rows long by two columns
wide
it shows us the type of data that each
of these columns comprises of so here
numvec is a double or numeric
column species vect is a character
column
and
yeah so it includes all of this neat
information here but actually the
coolest thing about tibbles is not
something we can see from this really
simple data set so let's create a table
using
our tree
data my tree tibble that's what i'll
call it
now taking a look at
my tree tibble
here's the really cool thing down here
it says with 21 more rows
now what's really nice about this
is that
if we had just looked at tree data not
as a typical so the original version of
tree data is not as a typical
here are the data
oh wait what are the column names oh we
have to scroll up a bunch to get to here
oh okay wow that's a lot of space i
don't want to have to like open this all
oh wait what happened to oh now i have
to how do i make oh i have to oh no
there we go okay
yeah you get my point
tibbles are really cool there's a bunch
of other advantages to them too but for
now i'm just gonna say they're they're a
neat and simple way to
look at and work with data frames so now
moving on to the next function
as dot data dot frame
sometimes you end up working with
matrices
and that you want to convert to a data
frame so for example
up here again we have we use the as dot
matrix to convert some kind of just
going backwards now
we can take our original data frame
convert it to a matrix using as dot
matrix don't need to know that function
i'm just kind of showing you
trying to create a matrix here to show
you what i mean so here we have this
simple matrix of values usually you end
up working with matrices when you're
creating species by sight matrices for
for multivariate ordinations in ecology
and community
when you're dealing with community data
and ecology and and that kind of thing
so
that's usually where you'll encounter
matrices the most so let's say we have
this matrix here and we want to convert
it to a data frame
use as dot data frame
with my matrix
and
there it is
back to a data frame and along the same
lines we also have
as underscore tibble and the reason that
most of the so most of the functions
that come with d plier
have kind of done away with using dots
or periods to to separate out words in
functions and instead use underscores
and the reason for that is that
if you're a python programmer
the dots actually are read in a
different way than they are in r where
in r they just kind of become part of
the name of the function whereas in
in python they actually are an operator
that indicates uh something a little bit
more than just part of the name of the
function and so for that reason to kind
of simplify things and make them
kind of universally understandable
between the two languages that's that's
my understanding maybe someone knows or
understands a better reason for why
why they've done away with the periods
so instead of as dot table here we have
as underscore table
for
for this function and what this does is
it actually does the same thing as as
dot data frame as dot data.frame but
converts things into a table so actually
up here we
probably sh instead of using table tree
data we really should have used as
table because that can actually give you
some errors
but if we use as table
oh let's take a look at that
here is our tree data table
okay
now on to
as dot matrix oh i guess i am going to
go over that yep so i already did as
that matrix is useful when you want to
create species by sight matrices and
some functions require that you that you
enter matrices into their arguments
rather than
than data frames and so that's what you
would use as dot matrix for
so again here is the matrix of values
based on this original data frame that
we had
so with matrices sometimes you need to
swap them around so swap what is in the
column make the columns into rows and
make the rows into columns
and we can do that with the
t function or i think that stands for
transpose
let's see
t matrix transpose yes okay i was right
all right so when we run this
function on my matrix
here we have that same matrix but the
columns and rows have been reversed
then we have the n call
and the n row functions
which is just a quick useful way to get
how many columns or rows we have in a
data set so let's look at our tree data
and call
looks like we have four columns in the
tree data
and row looks like we have 31 rows in
the tree data
simple as that nothing more to it so i
did mention the tibble as being quite
superior to the data frame because in
what well one of the most useful things
is that it
nicely and neatly cuts off your data
frames that you can just see the top 10
entries i guess
you can also change what that value is
but either way you see the top few
entries instead of having to scroll
through the whole data set
but another way to take a look at that
using just a typical normal data frame
is using the head function
and that just returns the top few
entries of a data frame so if we look at
tree data
and use head
i think the default is six the top six
rows so here we see the top six rows of
the tree data
the reason this isn't as great as
using a table to begin with is
it can be a little bit misleading if you
didn't realize that you ran the head
function because it doesn't tell you
that there's more rows in this data
frame that are missing
it's just a quick way to extract the top
little bit of a data set
okay now i'm going to
talk about one more function that i use
tremendously
i love it it's very useful there's a lot
of ways to use it and that is the
left
join function
now note there's also a right join and a
few other types of joins which you can
learn about by searching them here but
i'm just going to talk about left join
and then you can figure out the rest
after that so what this does is it is
used to combine two data frames based on
a reference column and this again also
uses the deep plier package
so make sure to install and load that
library first so let's say
let's let's create two data frames so we
can actually
show how this works
um let's see
let's take a look at tree data let's
let's use it as a table let's use the my
tree tibble
since i keep talking about how great
tibbles are
we take a look at the tree data okay
let's
add a column that indicates the
identity of the tree
so which tree we're dealing with we'll
just do that by saying
tree id
and i think there's 31 rows total yeah
so here we have 10 rows with 21 more so
that's 31 rows
so into tree id we're just going to say
add in the values of 1 through 31 and
we'll make this
as dot character
just so that the it's clear that these
numbers don't mean anything as a number
but they're just the identity of each
tree
let's take a look at my treat table
so here we have this new column now
called tree id
okay and let's say we have let's make a
new data frame now
tree id
one through thirty one
let's
let's create it was with the table
function
so tree id is one through thirty one and
then let's see let's make up some data
tree
leaves let's just say we could count how
many leaves each tree has i don't know
i'm just making this up again let's just
say tree leaves equals let's
i'm going to use a few extra functions
here just to make this easy so i'll
actually let's do run if
so that's picking a random number
from a uniform distribution and when we
type in we get this little
window that pops up that shows us what
we can enter in it now i'm not getting
that to pop up again
there we go
n is the number of values min and max so
we'll say
n equals 31
min equals
3 000
max
equals 5 000 leaves let's say and the
problem is that these values if we run
just that
they're they give us decimals as well so
let's just round that to whole numbers
since
let's just say we can only count entire
leaves and not partial parts of leaves
so round
that should be enough
run that taking a look at this one more
time yep there we go we have these 31
different
leaf counts for these different trees
and we're adding that as column tree
leaves
so now let's say that is
my
tree
leaf
data
taking a look at this we have this data
set with the tree id and the number of
leaves for each tree
and then we have this other data set
that has these other variables and tree
id but doesn't have the leaf data
so we combine these together with the
left join function
so typically
the first data set that goes on the left
is the one that has almost everything
already in it
so here we'll put in my tree tibble
and then the next data set is the data
set that contains the data we want to
add to it my tree leaf data
and then we add in one more argument
that says by equals
tree id this tells the function let's
take these data and then take these data
and add them to these data
and match it up so that every value in
this data set is matched up to this data
set based on a matching tree id value in
this case it's actually the same order
because tree ids are in the same order
so let's mix up that order actually
to prove my point
so i'm just going to index this
and i'm just going to sample
31 values
from 1 through 31 that gives us a random
order to everything
and let's save
that into itself
so now if we take it tree leaf take a
look at tree leaf data now all the tree
ids are all mixed up
but they're still associated with each
particular number of tree leaves so now
if we do left join and let's save this
as my data all
now if we run left join it should
connect these two data sets by tree id
error can't join because of incompatible
types ah i know why because up here we
saved it as dot character but here we
did not so let's say as dot
character
it's trying to combine numbers with
letters and that doesn't work
even though they're both numbers one of
them's a character so it doesn't know
what to do with that let's do that again
there we go no error now let's take a
look at my data all
and there it is
now we have these tree leaves attached
to this other data set so if we let
let's take a look at tree id one tree id
one is four five six seven oh that's
convenient that's easy to remember four
five six seven let's take a look at
the
original my tree leaf data
oh look it's in the top ten
number one is four five six seven and so
it was able to successfully combine
those two data sets now note that if we
didn't include this by equals tree id in
here
r is pretty smart
when we run that it shows us joining by
equals tree id because it found that
that is the only column that's in common
between the two data sets if there
wasn't a column in com between the two
data sets we'd get an error if we did
that
all right now let's get on to the basics
of data wrangling this is where it gets
really fun and a little more advanced
but you can do some really cool things
here
all of these functions are going to use
the dplyr package
so if you haven't installed and run the
library function for dplyr
do so now
and the first first function we're going
to go over is the select function
and this is simply used for filtering
and renaming columns that you want to
keep or remove from a data frame
going back to let's use this new data
set that we created my
my data all
so the first argument of these functions
is always the data set that you want to
use
so in this case we'll use the my data
all that we created just now if we take
a look at this we've got a bunch of
different columns here dbh height volume
light tree id and the number of leaves
in the tree
um
so we can use select to select which
columns we want to keep let's say we're
only interested in
dbh and height and tree id
so we can just say
dbh
height
tree id
it's that simple when we run that
function
now we get a new data frame table that
just consists of dbh height and tree id
now we could have also let's say we
wanted to keep everything but we wanted
to remove
tree volume
so all we would have to do is put in a
minus sign and then volume
just like that
and now we remove tree volume from this
data frame and let's say we want to
rename some of the columns in this data
frame let's say tree leaves is a little
ambiguous and we want to rename it to
leaf number
we can just say
leaf
number
equals
and then that column was called tree
leaves actually don't even need those
parentheses
tree leaves
so now
we only want to remove
volume
but we want to keep everything else and
rename leaf number equals tree leaves
and run that
now we have everything except for volume
and leaf and tree leaves was renamed to
leaf number
now if we only included
leaf number equals tree leaves that will
only select the column tree leaves and
remove everything else
oops just like that
so make sure that you include what you
want to keep or what you want to remove
and then what you want to rename
so that's what the select function does
then we have the filter function
and what this does is if select is to
filter out which columns you want to
keep the filter function is to filter
out which rows you want to keep
the first argument again is my data
and then it's simply a
any kind of a statement that generates
trues and falses based on the number of
rows that you have
so
we could say let's take a look at all
the data
we could say say we want to keep
all the trees that had a dbh greater or
less than 11. we want to keep only these
trees in our data set that are less than
11. so we'll create this true false
statement and say
that's true dbh so we'll say
we want to keep everything where dbh
equals
actually is less than 11.
so when we run that
we're left with just those rows
and you can add multiple statements on
here
so we could say
we want everything where
dbh is less than 11
and
height is greater than or equal to 70.
so when we run that
now we have only those heights
where
the tree is greater than 70 and dbh is
less than 11.
and so note that every additional
argument that you add onto the filter
function
with a comma is the same as saying and
so i want to filter for everything where
this
is true and this is true if you want an
either or
instead of a comma
you can just use this vertical line i'm
not sure what it's called on my keyboard
it's right above the return key when i
hold shift down and what this says is i
want to filter all my data where this is
true or this is true
so when we do that we get a whole lot
more data next we have the mutate
function and this is used to create new
columns in your data frame or to modify
existing ones again all of these
packages you all these functions use the
deployer package
so once again first argument is our data
set
and let's say we want to right now our
height is measured in feet but let's say
we want to convert our height to meters
and so to do that we
have to multiply the height by
0.3048 that's just the conversion to
convert it to meters and so to create a
new column in our data set we can name
it whatever we want
so in this case
height meters
equals
and then we'll just say height
times 0.3048
it's as simple as that
this new column that we want we can name
it whatever we want equals height times
whatever
so now if we take a look at our data
height in meters we have it right here
and so if we wanted to add a few
different new columns
we can just hit a comma
and let's say we want to do
height in
[Music]
we'll just call it height modified and
it'll be height times
0.05
whatever that
means we can also hit return here
because r is not
line or space sensitive for for certain
things like this
to keep it a little bit more neat we can
hit return there so then here we can
clearly see what all the different
columns that we're creating are
and if we run this now we have two
additional columns height meters and
height mod that have been added on
you can also modify the existing ones
like let's say
let's say we don't want to rename hype
but we just want to
modify it so that it's height in meters
i'm going to remove this
for simplicity i'm just going to
call that height so now what it's going
to do is it's going to say
in this column height we're going to
take height multiply it by that but
because height is the same name as the
existing column it will just replace the
original values with these new ones
so now if we take a look under height
height has already been converted to
meters in this case
okay moving on
we're going to use the summarize
function
so this summarizes all the different
columns in your data frame
if we put in the
my data all again here we have to enter
in
what summary values do we want
so for example maybe we want to find out
the
mean height
and we'll call that
and mean height will be based on the
mean
height so applying the
applying the function mean which i'll go
over in a little bit
to the column height and then let's say
we also want to know
the maximum
girth
or maximum dbh
and we'll use the function max which
we'll also go over in a bit later but
it's pretty self-explanatory
so now if we run this
we simply get
this table with mean height
and maximum dbh now you might wonder if
you're just creating summary values for
all the columns why create a table
if there's only going to be one row of
these summary values of the in this case
the mean height and the maximum dbh and
that's because summarize can be combined
with the group by function which is
really neat
and the group by function allows us to
split the data set into individual
groups
for example let's say
group by
let's group the data into whether the
trees were in the sun or the shade
so we'll just use group by first
arguments the data again
and we'll just say we want to group by
light that's the name of that column
oops
so if we run that
you'll notice nothing really changes
it's the same data set but up here
we have this thing that says groups
light and the two tells us that there's
two different groups in this case there
was just shade or light or shade or sun
or whatever it was
so on its own it doesn't really do much
but then if we take this grouped data
and put it inside of this summarize
function
so i'm just going to copy this over
again
copy that and in place of my data all
i'm going to put in this group by
function so now my data all has been
grouped and then we're putting it into
the summarize function
and now take a look and now we have one
row for each of the different groups
that we had grouped the data by so now
we have the mean height
for shade trees we have the mean height
for sun trees and the maximum dbh for
shade trees and sun trees
and when you use the summarize function
with the group by function it actually
automatically removes the grouping
afterwards
so you'll notice here there's no
remaining grouping in the data but
sometimes it's useful to
ungroup
with the data to make sure that
something doesn't go wrong down the line
so for example
we could have
grouped by my data group so i'm just
saving this data set this data frame as
its own new data frame that's grouped
oops
call that grouped
if we take a look at this same data
frame but up here we've got this
indication that it's grouped by light
and then we can put that into summarize
and run that
and so here is the data set or the
summary of that data set based on light
but then we might want to do something
else with these data and we want to
ungroup them
because they're still grouped so we'll
put them in this ungroup
and when you run that
oops it's the same data set again but
you'll notice the grouping variables
have disappeared
and you can also use the group by
function
with the filter and mutate so for
example if you want to
filter for
all if you want to remove or or extract
only the tallest trees
from the sun group and the shade group
if you just used
max height so which height equals max
height in this filter you'd only get one
tree value because it's the maximum the
tree with the tallest height out of the
whole data set but if you group the data
first based on light and applied this
filter it would actually extract it
would extract the tallest tree from each
of the groups that you had grouped by so
the group by function can be really
really useful
all right we are almost done
and actually we've covered most of the
functions in this last section on basic
statistics but i'll quickly go over them
one more time
we've got the lm or linear model
function
this is the
most basic function for doing any kind
of statistical analysis in r
it allows you to do everything from
t-test to anova regression multiple
regression etc they all fall in that
same category of simple linear models
and so a simple way a simple example of
this would be
let's
do a linear model of
dbh
is a function of so remember this tilde
indicates
is a function of or the y varia what's
left on the left of it is the y variable
on the right of it are the x variables
so let's say we want to model dbh as a
function of
light so the sunlight
and what else do we have to work with
as function of sunlight and the number
of leaves
so remember leaves were just random we
just created this random data set so
tree leaves shouldn't actually really be
an important predictor of dbh but let's
just see what happens so
a simp a simple model would be just
how is dbh a function of light and then
the and then we add the data in here
my data all
so this would be the simplest way to do
to do this and since light is two
different categories you can kind of
think of this as a t-test is there a
difference in dbh between these two
different variables
and we'll save this as mod one
and so we take a look at mod 1
it doesn't really give us much to work
with it just gives us the estimate for
the coefficients in this model
but the summary function
not to be confused with the summarize
function from before just summary
will give us a more detailed summary of
these model results
so here we have
the model formula the residuals the
coefficients and then the p-value
whether these differ whether the
intercept and the slope in this case the
effect of light is significant
and a few other test statistics and
information and you should check out my
other video on doing basic linear
regression in r if you're interested in
learning more about how this works i'm
not going to go over the details now
just want to show you how to use this
function
now we could have also added in some
more variables so for example
[Music]
we'll add in
so let's say we think tree leaves are
also a predictor of dbh
it might actually be the other way
around but either way let's run that and
now take a look at the summary
and
we have the same results as before with
sunlight appearing to be significant
but then tree leaves
do not have a significant effect or
association with dbh in this case
now there's a lot of assumptions to this
because it's a linear model but again
i'm not going over any of the stats here
just wanted to show you how this works
then we have the
mean function which we've gone over
already i think i used it a bunch of
times it just calculates the mean value
from a from a vector so if we use numvec
here
the mean value of numvec is happens to
be five and if we have an n a value
we can't actually calculate the mean
because it will just give us an n a so
remember you can also use n a dot r m or
n a dot remove equals true and then it
will calculate the mean after removing
the n a
then we have max and min
let's use let's actually use our data
here so let's see what the maximum
height is
87 feet
let's see the
and then we have the minimum
the minimum tree height is 63 feet
and so on
then we also have median
which is different from mean because it
gives us
the
value where 50 of the data are below
that value and the other 50 percent are
above that value
in the data set
so our median value in this case
with tree heights
is 76
if we did our mean value it might be
close to the median but there are cases
where the median is more important or
more
informative than the mean and vice versa
but let's just add a curiosity's sake
let's see what the mean value
of tree heights is there's also 76 all
right well that makes sense given enough
data that fall under a normal
distribution the mean and median should
be the same thing
and finally last but not least
the function that i think is quite
underrated very few people ever mention
it but i just love this function because
it's
a really quick way to get a nice summary
of any categorical variables that you
have in your data and that is the table
function
so in our data set here that we've been
working with let's say we want to get a
quick summary of how many trees were in
the shade and how many trees were in the
sun
we'll just apply this table function
with
my data all
to light
and we have this quick output that shows
us 15 trees we're in the shade and 16
trees we're in the sun
and if you have a more complex
categorical variables such as maybe you
have a column for different species and
you're dealing with hundreds of
different species maybe even just tens
of different species but you have a huge
data set and you just want to see how
many data points do you have available
for each species
then you would run that and you get this
nice little table of the different
species names and how many individual
observations you have for each
so that is it that concludes the
functions that i covered in my essential
functions of our
cheat sheet
hey i hope you enjoyed this tutorial
if you did make sure to click the like
button down below it really helps me be
able to share my videos as much as i can
get them out there get as many people to
see them as possible
be sure to subscribe if you want to get
more updates whenever i post new videos
and again if you really like this and
want to kind of take it a step further
be sure to check out my course on the
basics of our for ecologists there's a
link down below in the description
and you can subscribe right there to
find out when the next course enrollment
opens up
so with that i hope you have a great
rest of your day and
see you next time
[Music]